il ya toujours l'objectif bikini se
marrent body est en fait c'est terrible
parce qu'on est en train de te dire en
gros pour être heureux pour te sentir
bien cet été pour profiter de ton été il
faut faire 1 34-1 36,7 tout lisse ne
surtout pas avoir de ses limites
[Musique]
j'ai grandi avec des complexes et le
pire c'est que suis toujours complexe et
et je me bats tous les jours pour pour
arrêter d'être complexe et je crois que
je suis je suis d'une génération
nous en a foutu vraiment plein la gueule
avec les stéréotypes les injonctions les
diktats et moi j'étais extrêmement
touché par tout ça parce que je suis une
nana très grande donc j'ai eu une
enfance j'étais plus grande que les gars
sont plus grandes que mes copines donc
plus lourde que mes copines j'avais des
plus grands pieds que mes copines le
fait qu'on appelle aux femmes à l
approche de l'été
comment elles doivent être qu'est ce
qu'elles doivent manger le poids
qu'elles doivent faire pour rentrer dans
la matinée par exemple ça c'est quelque
chose qui m'a fait énormément complexé
qui avait je suis pas là la plage
pendant des années
[Musique]
personne n'est choqué qu au mois d'avril
à la proche de rites et les pubs
absolument partout que ce soit en 4 par
3 dans le métro dans les magazines sur
les réseaux sociaux à la télé à la radio
avec des nanas qui font à 1,36 qui ont
12 ans ont dit voilà rentre dans ton
grande en bikini cet été par exemple ça
je trouve ça horrible mais ça passe
c'est normal par contre on dit pas
attention montrer toujours un corps fin
parfait toulis ça peut faire souffrir
des femmes au point d'en rendre malade
certaines en tire une tronche
d'accord c'est parce que c'est bientôt
l'été c'est ça commence à tuer peut être
mettre en maillot
je vois le nombre de nana que ça touche
en fait on est beaucoup trop à souffrir
et quand j'ai lancé ce hashtag objectif
bikini ferme ta gueule
je m'attendais absolument pas autant
d'ampleur et ce qui m'a le plus surpris
c'est que ça me semble un message
tellement simple tellement normal en
avoir marre de tout ça et en fait ça
prend une ampleur de dingue parce que
personne ne le dit et pourtant ça fait
chier tout le monde moi al'approche de
l'été je me dis surtout depuis quelques
années ils ont je vais me défoncer des
barbeuk je vais aller en terrasse avec
mes potes boire des bières et m'éclater
et [ __ ] je veux lâcher la pression
malheureusement on est conditionné les
femmes sont conditionnées à une certaine
image et j'ai l'impression qu'on accepte
un peu ça on accepte un peu d'être
conditionné il suffit de l'ouvrir pour
que ça change vraiment il faut essayer
de poster un peu moins de photos on se
met dans des positions improbables
il faut essayer de se montrer un peu
plus normale vous êtes vrais êtres réels
donc essayer de montrer un maximum que
vous êtes réel avec internet est
vraiment vraiment vraiment attirer les
regards sur vous essayez de les attirer
autrement